hi hello i'm rafael tamayor from
collider
um i wanted to ask uh all of you
um when you first got the script and and
started learning about the project what
was the first thing that popped to your
head that you wanted to add to your
character
oh
oh that's a good question
i don't know i mean i'm not sure there
wasn't anything that i wanted to add i
think
i'm always thinking business so
[Music]
no i mean i i don't think there was
anything that i wanted to add i mean i
think jorge brought us all on hopefully
because he wanted us specifically for
these roles and i think
you know he had had this world so
fleshed out like it it's an incredibly
densely
thought about world that feels
it feels like a thick
thought out world the way like lord of
the rings feels you know there's all
these different lands there's all these
different
references there's references that are
like aztec mayan
inca references um current day caribbean
references there's like
it's really rich and beautiful and
gorgeous and i i just was like can i lay
i would love to be in it that would be
amazing you know like that's really i
was like
that's it i i just showed up and brought
my imagination and voice but it was so
fleshed out
um gabriel you specifically i i was
fascinated by how
different your character sounds from uh
pretty much anything you've done before
um i was wondering how was that uh for
you getting to create the voice of
peacho
uh you know well jorge and i went back
and forth because he felt that my voice
didn't fit the character enough
because he's you know the character's so
just big and he's very uh slow and
lethargic and kind of just you know so
he's like i need
give me something that sounds a little
bit more you know and i'm like all right
so uh we we went back and forth for a
while until we we settled on the me when
i wake up voice which is that
where's the bathroom
and he's like oh i love it i love it you
know when jorge gets excited about it
himself he's like oh it's the best i
love it
i'm clapping for it i'm like okay that's
that's what we're gonna go go with right
there but
yeah that the voice is real deep and
groggy and slow so everyone so yeah it's
that's me in the morning 7 am that's
exactly what i sound like
similarly um allen and stephanie did you
was there a particular moment when you
thought okay now i i got the answers of
my character i know how to do this
oh man it was kind of laid out to me
early so um just kind of getting the
essence of who rico was was kind of it
was on the page man everything it was so
detailed um
like stephanie said like he he he paints
this picture where it's hard to miss
like
it's hard to start to mess with jorge on
your side so uh you know he's definitely
the captain of the ship that just
steered us in the right direction
i would agree with that
there's a lot of physicality to all of
your characters a lot of action in the
film uh this being animation do you do
anything to to to sort of evoke that in
your performance how do you get into
that mindset when you are on the
recording booth
oh i i mean that's so it's so fun to be
doing that stuff in the recording booth
there's no the only self-consciousness
is whatever you are self-conscious about
because you're not being recorded
you know on film so you can just go wild
and like try everything it's really fun
i find it really freeing those kinds of
things yeah i'm pulling up in sweats and
slippers man like i'm
like i'm comfortable i'm comfortable i'm
in there
and you just let it go man sometimes
there's some uh physical movements that
go along with it even though you're
behind the mic but it just it just helps
you you know uh evoke that emotion that
you need for whatever line that you have
so um yeah no
doing the voiceovers it's all about the
physicality sometimes just that's how
you get the sound the way it sounds
yeah for me uh the last session i got
actually got to do from from home so you
know again you just want to be relaxed
feel free i i went full win to the pool
when i did my recording
and uh yeah that's that's you know you
can you can hear it in the last
recording
[Laughter]
fuzzy with the ears he means they went
in costume that's what
for all of you was there any uh because
this movie has so
um a grounded feeling like this is a
real world these are real people um did
you
what do you draw inspiration from when
you when it came to your performances or
if any
again
the inspiration was in in the script in
the story and the message that um you
know jorge was trying to convey in which
i believe he did with um all of our
characters and just the meaningfulness
of each character and um
who and how we we meant to each other in
each other's lives at these particular
moments like everybody's going through
something
like
every character going through something
they going through something heavy
and together we kind of you know find a
way to figure it out within ourselves as
a group so um it was again it's it was
all kind of laid out for us we just had
to run to play
very well played
thank you so much guys and
congratulations on the film thank you
brother
you